bien on va continuer de se faire du bien
avec tiphaine feuilles fleurs qui est
avec nos bons jo tiffen mangeurs pascal
gers il être au rendez vous
régulièrement avec vous on découvre des
sélections livre ensemble pour nos
enfants
à voir ou à revoir sur les réseaux
sociaux et ce matin vous allez nous
proposait finalement passer du petit au
grand écran pour faire découvrir
l'histoire du cinéma aux enfants c'est
ça à nous parce que les enfants ignorent
souvent en fait d'où vient d'où viennent
les images animées et puis bien quand
est ce qu elles ont été créées puisque
finalement et bien pascal nous ne
serions pas là s'il n'y avait pas eu
l'invention du cinématographe et l'image
animée n'a que 125 ans donc pour tout
savoir et plonger faire un petit bond en
arrière et bien il ya ce livre c'est
quoi la magie du cinéma publiée par gulf
stream
alors c'est écrit par réjane amusé
vallée et s'est illustré par clémence
l'allemand alors je vous conseille
vraiment se livrent déjà parce qu'il
tient dans la poche
et ça c'est bien pratique et aussi parce
qu'il propose une mine d'informations
alors la naissance du cinématographe
déjà en 1895 par les frères lumière mais
aussi beaucoup d'autres informations
comment créer une image animée
qu est ce qu un effet spécial pourquoi
il ya différents types de films des
comédies des tragédies comment on classe
tout ça et puis il y à même à la fin des
idées d'ateliers pour créer en fait ses
propres images animées
donc c'est une collection déjà en
général qui plaît beaucoup
ça s'appelle un deux trois partez vous
trouverez plein d'autres volumes plein
d'autres thèmes
mais ce livre là sur le cinéma vraiment
je vous le conseille
c'est quoi la magie du cinéma avec
paraît-il un petit jouet à l'intérieur
un jouet optique sympathique nommé
thaumatrope c'est ça et bien vous
pourrez le créer en fait il ya tout pour
le créer vous voyez vous vous avez
toutes les indications et puis il ya
quatre ateliers comme ça de vous avec
vos enfants et bien vous prenez du
carton et puis vous créez tout ça et
vous verrez vous pourrez faire bouger
les images moi j'adore c'est tout ce qui
fait la magie du
cinéma et ça c'est bien alors parmi les
acteurs qui ont fait l'histoire du
cinéma
il ya forcément quelqu'un que vous
connaissez jean louis et christophe si
je vous fais comme ça avec donc ça vous
parle ça vous parle je le fais très
malin mais non ça vous parle pas charlot
ouais je sais pas si ces charlots c'est
quelqu'un qui a un peu froid sur un
plateau non non c'est charlie chaplin
il a connu le muet le parlant est aussi
la couleur et on va le retrouver au
travers d'un petit ouvrage que vous avez
sélectionné
oui alors là on part en 1912 en fait au
moment où il arrive aux états unis grâce
à cette bande dessinée qui s'appelle
chaplin en amérique de laurent seksik et
david françois c'est publié chez rue de
sèvres alors c'est plutôt pour les
adolescents et les adultes 1 évidemment
et l'idée c'est d'expliquer comment
charlie chaplin est devenu charlot
justement puisque au départ quand il
arrive aux états unis et bien lui son
objectif ces deux conquérir hollywood
mais ça ne se passe pas vraiment comme
prévu parce que quand ils arrivent à new
york on trouve qu'il a un accent anglais
détestable et qu'il joue très mal
en fait sa carrière va vraiment
commencer quand il part à los angeles et
qu'il invente vous l'avez dit charlot
alors vous le fait moins bien que vient
je suis désolé pascal mais c'est
vraiment ce personnage qui va en fait
lui offrir sa carrière incroyable
alors ça c'est le premier tome il y en
aura encore deux apparaître puisque la
carrière de charlie chaplin est immense
alors vous voyez le coup de crayon de
david françois rend bien en fait
l'hyperactivité de charlie chaplin son
goût pour la réussite son ambition est
le récit rend bien oui si son côté macho
en car il n'était pas tendre non plus
vraiment je vous conseille cette bande
dessinée et puis ça permet aussi de
reparler en fait de ce réalisateur
acteur compositeur que j'adore
personnellement avec un peu oublié en ce
moment mais je sais pourquoi pour
charles ou est ce parce qu'il me
manquait la can
c'est pour ça qu'on aime c'est vrai
faire plus appliqué ce quidam quoi bon
pour les enfants et puis aussi les
parents un finalement que le cinéma fait
rêvez vous avez trouvé un ouvrage à
avoir vraiment dans toutes les
bibliothèques c'est quoi ce conseil ça
s'appelle les coulisses du cinéma de
adam al sud boardman c'est publié par
game arts c'est à partir de 11 ans donc
c'est vraiment accessible à tous alors
pourquoi je vous conseille c'est parce
qu'on remonte des origines a maintenant
ça parlait à la fois des métiers du
cinéma de l'histoire du cinéma des plus
grands réalisateurs on retrouve par
exemple
alfred hitchcock mais aussi fritz l'inde
méliès et on parle aussi des images
iconiques en fête du cinéma des choses
qu'on oublie un peu par exemple la lune
de méliès ou la créature de frankenstein
alors vraiment je conseille ce livre en
plus il est très accessible parce que
vous le voyez en fait ce sont des
dessins qui se rapproche de la bande
dessinée donc pour un enfant et bien ça
donne tout de suite envie de le lire
et puis il ya un grand grand chapitre
sur star wars
donc en ce moment et bien pas de souci
là vous allez intéresser tout le monde
petits et grands puisque ça permet de
parler bien des effets spéciaux et des
trouvailles lié à star wars
et puis ça parle des métiers du cinéma
donc ça donnera forcément envie aux
enfants d'aller au cinéma et peut-être
d'en faire on ne sait jamais bah oui ça
peut susciter des vocations moi je sais
pas on peut par exemple devenir
réalisateur pourquoi pas et oui et j'ai
un dernier livre alors non je voulais
absolument vous parler c'est plutôt un
kit en fait ça s'appelle réaliste et
films sur ton smartphone c'est aussi
publié chez gallimard et c'est une super
idée
alors c'est un kit alors je peux pas
tout vous montrer en même temps mais il
ya de quoi en fait savoir comment
réaliser un film avec tout le storyboard
le scénario ici il y à des planches pour
justement dessiner son story bat vous
voyez il ya des petites cases blanches
on vous explique aussi qu'il faut
recruter une équipe comme encadré
comment faire un plan large un plan
serré et à la fin une fois vous avez
tous dessinés et même filmé avec votre
smartphone évidemment puisque ça tout le
monde en a un à la maison
et bien vous pouvez projeté en ayant un
construit le projecteur et avant la
projection il faut distribuer des
tickets et les pop corn
ouais pas mal seulement que les glaces
mais après alors je vous le dis tous les
gens de la rédaction l'orne sur se
quittent donc quand on fait des images
sur petit écran
on fait comme on rêve quand même en fait
de faire du cinéma merci merci merci
tiphaine pour ses judicieux conseils
d'une maman averti vous savez quand vous
parlez avec vos enfants
très bien je précise que la sélection
livre est aussi à retrouver sur le net
évidemment